Fatima dawood replants her Farm after
the previous crop failed
it's been weeks since any significant
rainfall in Eastern China
now she can only wait and hope for a
change in the weather
the rains were better last year at this
time I fear this could mean poor harvest
or worse
pharmacies say they continue to see less
and irregular rainfall resulting in crop
losses
but it's not only poor rains that's
causing so much pain to Farmers
even when the rains come we lack the
necessary tools to cultivate crops seeds
are beyond our reach
with each passing year the area of
cultivated Landing Chad shrinks as the
effective climate change become more
severe agriculture output is also
reduced
Lake Chad which provides livelihoods for
Millions who live around it continues to
shrink in size from 25
000 square kilometers 50 years ago to
just one thousand today due to drought
and climate change
that jeopardizes the jobs of 20 million
people
and fuels food shortages as well as
higher prices Global Supply challenges
caused by the pandemic and the war in
Ukraine have worsened things here food
inflation has risen to such a level that
families are forced to skip a meal in
order to afford the next the lack of
security has also affected food
production
cases of malnutrition are increasing
today we have already 2 million people
in Chad chadians people under severe
malnutrition it's I think the third
fourth times in the last decade that we
have such such an issue with food
insecurity
that was even before the arrival of 270
000 recently arrived soon in his
refugees in addition to the 400 000
already here for the past 20 years all
further complicating the already serious
food shortage in this landlocked country